u.s president joe biden pledged this
week to take a more active role in
diplomacy over ukraine in an effort to
deter russian leader vladimir putin from
a feared invasion of ukraine
but up uh rather up to 150 000 russian
troops by some estimates are massed
along ukraine's borders u.s intelligence
analysts warren moscow could be
preparing to stage military invention
early in the new year
but is an all-out war between two
countries whose populations are so
deeply intertwined really possible
dw's nick conley has been to the town of
milovet in eastern ukraine's border
region with russia to find out how the
locals feel
this muddy track used to be an
international crossing from ukraine to
russia
for helena and her neighbors with family
and friends on both sides it was a
lifeline
i want to check what kind of wire
they've put up oh yeah
yes yes it's barbed wire
and they've plowed this strip to catch
people who try to cross
a few signs some fencing and some barbed
wire
it might not look like a particularly
well defended frontier between two
countries in conflict but it's certainly
a big change for people in this part of
eastern ukraine who until a few years
ago could drive across the border
without as much as showing a passport
my neighbor has his elderly mother down
there on the russian side it's only six
kilometers from here but now he has to
do a huge loop and travel 10 times that
to pass through the border post
the board fence was first built a few
years ago helena tells us relatives
would come and stand on both sides to
talk over the barbed wire
it's this closeness these personal ties
that mean that many here aren't ready to
believe that armed conflict with russia
is even possible
we hear all the scary things on the news
but i just can't imagine it affecting us
here there's no animosity between us
that may be the case but the tanks and
the troops are definitely there even if
they're still some 200 kilometers from
helina's border village with u.s defense
sources warning invasion could be a
reality within months
we've been expecting a russian invasion
since 2014
they're always flexing their muscles
and i think this is just an attempt to
win political concessions
for now at least ukraine's top commander
in the region isn't convinced that war
is inevitable
but if armed conflict does break out
he's well aware that u.s or nato troops
will not come to ukraine's defense
we know we have only ourselves to rely
on
the weapons deliveries would make a big
difference
we need an anti-aircraft shield and if
we have that
any kind of intervention will be much
less likely
in the border town of milover there's
not much of that shield and evidence
with the russian and ukrainian border
guards barely a meter apart along the
boundary which runs down the middle of
the main street
but even here where many locals can see
russia from their windows it's covered
in economic worries rather than russian
tanks that for now are still weighing
most heavily on people's minds
how can we be in danger if the border's
right there we would have seen something
already
i've only seen those russian tanks on tv
we can't see or hear them here
no no tension's here
as negotiations between washington and
moscow to resolve these tensions go into
overdrive the people on the ground in
eastern ukraine seem unwilling to
believe that the threat of war is real
until they see those russian tanks with
their own eyes
i'll skip more now from lyanna fix she's
a political scientist and a program
manager at the kerber foundation with a
focus on russia and eastern europe
thanks for being with us ms fix russia's
troop buildup on ukraine's border was
the subject of a video summit earlier
this week between the u.s and russian
leaders has that done anything to
relieve tensions
well the summit was an attempt to
provide a diplomatic offer to really
critical situation at the moment so the
u.s president
presented moscow with two alternatives
either we find a diplomatic solution to
the situation right now or moscow is
going to face severe economic sanctions
from the united states and europe and
this is a strategy to prevent an
outbreak of war it has not yet relieved
tensions but it attempts to deter russia
from taking any further steps
us president biden will speak with
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
today now his country was once promised
nato membership something russia says it
will never accept help us understand why
moscow sees the possibility of ukraine
joining nato as such a threat
it's important to underline that at the
moment there have been no steps taken
whatsoever or there's no process for
ukraine to become a nato member and the
perspective is definitely entirely
unrealistic something kiev is also also
knows and is also aware about
so this russian argument about a
possible nato enlargement is at the
moment and will be in the future not a
valid argument it is rather an attempt
to at this moment after a long period of
frustration with diplomatic solutions
over ukraine to tighten control over the
over ukraine's territorial integrity and
independence
so this if we continue this line of
argumentation
we will see that it relates back to the
thinking about a sphere of influence
from the russian side which is something
that europe and the united states in its
immediate neighborhood obviously have
difficulties to accept would it not help
though if nato were to take that promise
of membership for ukraine in nato off
the table what do you think are the
steps needed now to prevent the russia
ukraine conflict from escalating further
if nato were to take this pledge it
would mean that the territorial
integrity and the independence of
ukraine and ukraine's choice as an
independent country that it can decide
its own foreign and security policy is
taken away and basically it is conceded
to russia that ukraine belongs to a
russian sphere of influence and has lost
would have lost some of its independence
which it already has lost in 2014 after
russia annexed crimea and um invaded in
eastern ukraine at a time when a nato
membership was also not on the table at
all so i think this is something we
should be aware that in 2014 the same
arguments have been made and
have been used by the russian side what
would be the next steps the next steps
would be definitely to find a diplomatic
off-ramp which revives the minsk process
which brings in the united states into a
diplomatic negotiation prospect and to
bring everyone back to the table rather
than um into the trenches
ms fix thank you very much that was
liana fix from the karma foundation